yeah hello and welcome to this video
going through the game between scarf and
cruelly two thousand and happy that this
was not the totally failed pronunciation
so let's get going and see what happens
in this game never Sicilian and scarf is
going from C for here on you three this
is not a very frequent DC move but it's
absolutely not bad at all why does the
Delaine for the central action with the
deep on trying to maybe get an oxy bind
kind of setup for example if black now
play some rather unless should we move
like let's say I know a six or so that
does it do all that much we would
actually get amarok see bind kind of
situation something that would not
happen for example if white plays deform
cakes takes an either fix this plate but
you have to yeah limit your C porn limit
yeah okay so see one being played here
by scarf and 96 that's a good reply now
d4 doesn't do all that much because
black has this variation which puts lots
of pressure on white center here black
is perfectly fine 93 light at six again
before there is the line I just show to
you we should be too so further delaying
things and now black has a choice to
make he needs to either take some kind
of stand in the center or claim a decent
waiting move some are better than others
here and the fire is the most principled
roof putting a pawn in the center here
while usually place this and get the
position which is entirely symmetrical
but white having the advantage of the
first move
this is believed to be equal at the end
but it is not much fun for black it's a
bit of a bleak prospects to play this
position so the typical Sicilian players
often want something is a little bit
more confrontational and Prince move is
one of those more confrontational moves
Queen 27 white now played 95 this is
some very very unusual in this position
and probably not all that great black
screen is a text but it has a good
square on on v8 so what is why it's
supposed to do now yeah the main thing
is that the e4 pawn now is of course a
tech and why it doesn't have a great way
to deal with this advancing the pawn no
you can cover it but just going back
really puts this whole action into
question you played these three first
and now after a six-strong back so white
has played basically d3 and the black
Queen was pushed to be eight this is
however not a problem at all like the
queen is not so bad on the square and
here if black so desires could have even
taken direct use of that by going to be
five that was a decent option now black
plate the move you should be six a
little bit unconventional but it is a
commonly seen motif in some Sicilians
that this Bishop is developed yeah in
front of the g7 pawn right now ok to
move Bishop g5 a little bit unsure about
that the bishop does not really want to
take on f6 and if you don't want to take
what exactly is superb
I mean maybe he wanted to take but it's
not a move that you generally want to
make because it would give up the dark
squares so clearly and for example I
mean black now played the move 9h five
but just let's just assume something
like this would have been played white
would absolutely never want to take here
because here black has given yeah he has
given black control over the dark
squares now if you have checked me five
and d4 yeah it doesn't look all that
great if you have points on light
squares and the light squared Bishop and
you've given up your dark squared bishop
just imagine this Bishop yeah somehow at
the end like showing up on deform it's
not a good prospect but black and did
not do that it played nine h5 if you're
absolutely dislike the idea of why
taking on f6 I think this was probably
the better option intending to go here
even though as mentioned there is no
threat of Bishop takes f6 I'm just
saying if you really more real concerned
yeah ok 9 h 5 I think white now should
probably go g3 you and simply let this
yeah night look a little bit silly on h5
very likely something like this is going
to happen and now deform and like with
this night h5 business has given up yeah
it didn't have an advantage but he had a
very comfortable situation this is now
gone it's probably equal to shegaon or
something along these assessments um
white now played the movie 5 this is an
interesting I actually suspect that that
was not intended as well it wasn't
intended one sacrifice but it is indeed
quite interesting so there is no big
choice Black has to take this part and
you cannot take with the night as you
would like to do as of course h5 is
under attack this is the only movie i
know what that is black I mean just
yeah if you want to try to ignore all
that then I can't that looks pretty
atrocious sis no this is no square
something friday on h5 and so taking is
this of this is pretty much mandatory so
takes takes and now the queen is
spinning the bishop so the night is not
hanging on h5 right now I think should
have played 22 this actually leads to an
interesting position with some
compensation for white white is a bit
better developed note that this is not
looking great and I think I'm not sure
if it's enough compensation but it is
some compensation something like that
the bishop to have form is f form now
why does a bit better develop t's
crossed the bishop pair I'm not sure
it's enough the computer think so no I'm
not completely convinced but I think
it's the best choice for white he played
this movie which is a little less
convincing as the Black Knight which was
an oxide piece immediately gets back
into the game ok white castle yeah and
black can yeah caption on Ani to greet
eggs and I think here hmm black should I
played the immediate 90 for putting this
into into the service we can square
immediately something like Queen d2
probably and it's it's it's probably
it's probably roughly equal might have
some compensation again there would be
four and so on yeah so what happened he
played this move and I think castles if
can be slightly risky and four and now
queen d 6 and this is a bad idea if
black now goes to c7 I think his
position is okay the first thing is is
why do we captures the pawn on c5
blackwell Goldie 6 and mainly opted for
position like that where the night is
blocking the f5 advance and b6 Bishop d7
is on the agenda equal maybe yeah the
thing is that the game move was just
much worse went to d6 and this is
leading into a position where I think
like can I mean I think why does a lot
better now 94 attack on the Queen the
Queen and it does not have any decent
square to go to if the Queen's drops
back the bishop will take and the thing
is if you haven't check this kind of
position this is just absolutely
atrocious for black I mean what kind of
what kind of game is that those pieces
are not moving ever and with f5 white is
going to have a decisive attack means
that black only has one reply after 94
this is the counter-attack 94 that was
played in the game and and him might
miss them very very instructive
opportunity he played the move Queen to
h5 this looks dangerous of course
because of the better development that
white have and he is not in bad shape
after this move however you have to also
look at night XD 6 in this position and
even more film as the lines that follow
are handy straightforward ok the Queen
has only taken King up has only one
square back and now I'm sorry the point
is then what can take on default and the
Pusha T 5 and this is extremely
extremely bad
this position and it's something that
white can easily calculate it is totally
force there are no sensible deviations
up to this point the problem is that
black is playing without the c8 bishop
and internal so cannot connect rooks if
white here would be able to play like a
four and a five black and safely resign
because it's going to play without to
pieces Blackham has to do something
quickly now very very quickly to avoid a
total bind and then I'm not sure that it
can do so anyway but we can try them a5
is probably the best tribe Luke c1 is a
strong move anticipating that black
probably wants to play some B 6 in the
nearest future so on how can we continue
this line for example what did my notes
a loop we ate and then I had a four as
an idea the idea is to go before takes
and 85 this is really important to see
if black plays let's say some some money
and you go here here here this is losing
this is not nothing else than losing
because this is a completely dead piece
why do pick up those two pawns and will
and then win very comfortably you are
peace up I can't count it actually as to
if you like the look isn't any better so
this is what why this is trying to do if
black goes b6 you can go before again
very strong takes takes bishop here
engines a five this is a losing position
for back this night is an absolutely
dominating piece again wise will
probably pick up those pawns and
and promote a and B porn I think that
why does more than winning here I mean
if we go back I think wine is more less
winning in the index position I mean in
a practical game black will lose I mean
very very clearly because it's even
difficult to ya have the computer
defended I mean the computer already
gives white almost the wind and
intellectual game tough very tough also
note that white is the pawn down but
this is totally irrelevant the other
pawn on d4 for example can be easily
picked up and pawns are nice but pieces
are more important here black Bishop on
state will probably do some the game um
in the game Queen h5 force plate and not
an illogical move and in itself but
night xe6 was forced and leading to
something extremely favorable so black
plate Queen to e7 and now I took and
went mad g5 directly going for the
attack and here there is something else
also I looked at 25 as well trying to do
this after all this is not bad and maybe
better than the game continuation this
is also taking it upon probably
something like f6 and d5 is a good
choice for like it looks very radical
but you need to get your bishop in the
game now so something like that for
example it's not too bad for black but
why it is also fine another move that
I've found most interesting is to move
f5 trying to play at six yeah if black
takes boutiques there is quite some
serious pressure here again there are
sometimes ideas to block this
496 those kind of things quite promising
however black will not take a play f6
this is a lot stronger also preventing
white from playing f6 I'm not sure about
this probably black is fine in this
position you can try and we have stuff
like that but it is extremely slow and
something like t5 is defending it the
wide turn a problem is also he only has
one night left as a minor teaster tech
and just with Queen and Rukia not going
to make black in the game this was
played conectate h6 have to do something
about the maid and now look at three
that was the white players idea going
for direct mating attack this should not
succeed but black now made a mistake and
he has a couple of moves actually
available it's not just like one
possible line one thing's clear though
he should not play what he did and
possible moves f5d 60 b6 move that
either block some squares away or
finally try to get the vision out this
for example is good because after Luke
h3 black hennessey five and ten doll
that looks a little bit silly if instead
of rupiah three and yeah some
conservative move was still ok and note
that that porn isn't strong so v6b six
at five all good now public but he took
this night and this should lose the game
because the wide attack is going to be
extremely strong look h3 white also
could have taken on g5 first the group h
three is ok there's nothing wrong with
the move
f6 eat from square and now takes ya hear
the main thread is g6 and black resigns
there is only this reply and here and
wide handling the check is correct but
the next move moved 24 is the problem he
now played three inch five check the
winning move the right she true it
doesn't matter what you do you need to
give a check on their farm I'm going to
do it with just but other way around
also wins yeah black only have this one
reply and now you can take and go look
at one and here black has no defense if
the Queen go somewhere here or here can
do that okay checkmate it's a direct
mate and it doesn't make a difference if
you go here here yeah it's always the
simplest made so the Queen has knows
where and this is Chet also made cheaply
quite quickly so a little bit of a
mystery what white overlooked here it's
a completely straightforward variation
yes you played this and black now sg6 it
does not need to repeat going to g8 g6
is good and look everyone check oh I'm
sorry press the wrong button everyone
check this is fine and King 38 yeah now
white can still draw by the way but you
have to play correctly now this is
extremely difficult however for a human
player to assess especially in our
typical yeah time-limited situation with
them at a time and he played Queen g6 in
the game which seems to be not enough
for a draw however the catcher seems to
be okay Black has fatigued with a queen
this is check checkmate nganimate so
here and now funny enough not this but
between g5 the Queen here ng5 is keeping
the black king from escaping and this is
surprisingly a draw yeah how do you find
out this is a draw if you are not in the
actual game you can just ask your engine
it says 000 but in the actual game it's
tough really tough I mean what you what
you immediately spot is that why
definitely has chances to draw because
of this very good activity however it
also wouldn't be totally unreasonable to
think that Queen and rook should have
winning possibilities because you know
look at that they don't play at all
however objectively speaking it seems to
be a draw what would happen in the
actual game is tough to say I can easily
see myself with black making a mistake
attention losing the game it's still not
easy at all what is a potential lying
down Queen g7 according to the engine
the only move that secures the draw
shows that it is not easy look h6 for
example not their only continuation d6
root g 625 this is a checkmate very
important this is also why the computer
actually believes that this is the
strongest move giving white some look
for the king still is wrong be 60 g6
Queen five and now check check give some
check there and enter but I'd like it
does have just a perpetual check now so
with the computer it always looks easier
drawing the game tough very tough to
evaluate between taking here and the
other line and is really not easy at all
so this is what happened yeah it was
very comparable to the other position
the difference is however that here the
black king is already on the eighth and
have chances to escape to 37 charges is
wrong and he goes to see sevens what I
was trying to save he goes to his cell
yeah now why this basically am yeah yeah
tried to reload something out he doesn't
have enough here for the material at all
yes we can we got to this position and
here is an absolutely key moment Black
now has the opportunity to win the game
right now and with this more funny
technical shot if the Queen takes some
black takes with his Queen and has
completely stopped any potential
swindles as simply white legs any fire
power there is not even a check inside
and after Luke takes this route 87 and
now we see with this double attack that
white is losing air at TG to a B 2 and
so on and the queen is traded so here
Luke g8 was a really strong black plate
this one or ever and after this white
has a great opportunity and it was taken
by the white clam before very strong
move the Queen was defending the e5 pawn
and after the form the Queen has nowhere
to go to besides thinking they'll all go
back to evade but both moves give up the
e5
all ok 26 Luke h7 the right move and
King had to go bag of course I cannot
just like that so goes back is now Queen
to e7 instead of 27 white already had
the staff check with a draw check check
check that's a perpetual but he played
Queen to e7 maybe even hoping for more
but it shouldn't change the cave Queen a
to now was possible but this is not yet
yes spoiling anything check and now King
you wanna cash it King it too and now we
have an absolutely key moment again as
lucky now sponsors efforts in this
really really tough game you place the
move Queen 33 probably happy that the
Queen's are traded however things are
not clear at all after that if you go
queen bee to instead and now grab here
yeah black should win this Queen covers
the bishop and you have a very
straightforward client King a seven and
then bring the wreckage of the game that
wins fairly easily instead can this move
and it shows that you have to be
extremely extremely circumspect with
going into an ending appeal of where the
other side have a clear plan and the
plan is promotion of the two points here
blacks position is not coordinated
those pieces are not yes situated well
it takes a lot of time until they play
together and such a pawn is very quickly
approaching its promotion square this is
not easy at all for black I think I
would have to be wise in this position
objectively it should be a dro I guess
35 nh-1 what white clearly has gotten
the initiative here note that also the
bishop is not helping all that much so
when a 5v5 was probably a better choice
that also helps that the king is finally
getting to do something this is a bit
too passive made King takes yeah and now
again White has two pawns and they are
dangerous King 86 and how to give black
some advice King be a was probably
better being there trying to run to the
action come from the back here you also
are in this van on the sixth-ranked
which can be potentially unlucky gyoo
cage six now was very strong the
computer actually assess in this
position as winning for why this is
possible the dip on Woodrow penned the
two points they're extremely dangerous
click for example something like here
and try to bring the bishop around we
take this intending c5 yeah and why this
pushing this side it doesn't look good
King apps warm it's not as convincing
because we're at eight now was a pretty
good defense this was played over but we
can have a look there check this is the
key idea they will get the terror get
activated still not easy but it's better
than than this move after which the pawn
yeah I get to be very very dangerous
again look at seven was the better
actually to prevent checks on the air
phone yeah check g68 Andrew 37 yeah and
now this is now a very mysterious moment
as black now did not take on g6 and this
is quite amazing if you have the
opportunity to sacrifice your bishop
again those two point you absolutely
have to do it I mean this is a fairly or
to f1 fairly straightforward draw three
against three and this is not a big
issue you have b5 coming yeah I mean
what can go away four bits the white is
not winning this position in the game
black took on d3 maybe trying to win but
this is not it's not very very realistic
so I would definitely I would have taken
there it's not objectively that terrible
it's just bit unnecessary to play with
fire g7 of course and yeah now be five
has to be played but he played a form
and after eight for age 6 Bishop g6 the
black position is critical however group
these samples such as up and down there
would be seven there is an issue later
as far as yet
[Music]
okay yeah why it takes this and now
really is an excellent shape and one
really necessary to take the porn but
okay it doesn't really matter those
advanced pong should should win 8 yeah
okay here here we have this this
situation at my notes animal did a bit
of a mess and yeah here this is attacked
and white has to have to check this yeah
you should not give up this palm what
you can do is you can play book before
check King moves and then would be sexy
and this you're going to wind quite
easily yeah this is a very
straightforward when you just go here
one if the route takes you go here and
now your ideas to eat push the King up
or go around here and wide wins this
fairly a fairly straightforward way the
thing is you have to keep your Pony of
course but white plate this and now
black was able to take it yes you can
try this idea but hoop 267 and here why
should use and draw this ending I mean
draw this ending I mean like will draw
the ending it is a draw anyway but it's
a far better way of doing it like this
here you actually have to be afraid that
blacks trying to wind us but in the
actual game check check like did not try
all that hard and you can ultimately
announcer the rook trade with precise
play black would have gotten into who
can bishop again through so there were
many ups and downs near the end of this
game we're certainly or most likely both
players played on the increment
always tough to do they were challenges
for white to win more than once in this
game I think the most important moment
on structive melon yeah it is here when
I taste the six was probably winning the
game in a pretty simple way simple means
that it's very difficult to imagine how
wide is going to screw this up now with
this basically material advantage that
you have with that fantastic piece down
I once ate a game where the night was
here that was even nicer and because you
guys heavenly who could never move I can
argue that it's nicer but it is very
good 3d scary good so I hope you enjoyed
the coverage of this fighting game
thanks for watching